you probably know Mark Andrews as a top
NFL tight end and Lamar Jackson's
favorite Target on offense but what you
probably didn't know is that he has to
check his blood sugar over 20 times a
game you see Mark Andrews has Type 1
diabetes and in a clip that went viral
recently Andrew admitted that he checks
his blood sugar every single time he
comes off the field if it's too low he
has to drink a Gatorade to help boost it
Andrews has been dealing with this
disease since he was 9 years old even
admitted that he used to think why me
why did I get this as a kid but he
clearly hasn't let it stop him he's
super grateful for the technology that
monitors his blood sugar and allows him
to play in the NFL he often Spends His
free time meeting with kids who also
have type 1 diabetes which has made him
a hero and inspiration for many on and
off the field